Many of us watch TV or play games on our phones
at night to unwind and switch into rest mode.
But more and more research says watching TV
in bed or falling asleep in front of the TV
is really bad for your health.
With all the streaming services releasing
full seasons as once, it’s easy to get sucked
in and say “just one more” until suddenly
it’s 3am and you’ve spent half your sleep
hours yelling at Dustin and the Demogorgon!
Then, when you DO finally crawl into bed,
you probably toss and turn and can’t sleep.
Because not only are you staying up and getting
all riled up, but the light coming out of
the TV itself is secretly messing with your
body clock!
Humans naturally have a roughly 24-hour circadian
cycle — for night owls it’s a little longer
and for early birds it’s a little shorter.
For humans, the cycle is highly influenced
by light -- evolution tells us that when it’s
light out we’re awake and when it’s dark
we sleep -- which makes light a driver of
our body clock.
Electric lighting has kinda knocked that out
of whack, and the devices we use have an even
stronger effect.
So, why you can’t sleep after Leslie Knope’s
recall, isn’t just your frustration, but
also specifically the type of light TVs emit.
TVs are mainly LCDs or LEDs, which emit a
lot of high-frequency blue wavelengths of
light.
Blue wavelengths boost attention and reaction
times, but but blue also has the strongest
ability to offset our body clocks.
A certain type of photoreceptor cell in our
eyes called melanopsin retinal ganglion, send
signals to the suprachiasmatic nucleus, essentially
the brain’s master clock.
Blue light tricks it into thinking it’s
daytime.
When hit with blue, the SCN suppresses secretion
of the hormone melatonin that helps us sleep,
and affects a host of other factors.
And it’s not just TVs!
Tablets, phones and laptops all have this
same blue problem.
As more and more of us take our phones to
bed and text or check Instagram late at night,
we’re getting the same blue light effects.
I know a lot of people use TV or scrolling
social media to relax your brains; it is one
of the most passive activities we can do.
But even though it’s good for relaxing,
it’s not good for falling asleep.
Blue light can delay your REM cycle enough
to disrupt sleep, and if you’re staying
up later to watch TV, the little sleep you
are getting is going to be worse quality,
which can lead to a bunch of other problems.
And sadly, our devices aren’t the only culprits.
Energy-efficient lighting also emits more
blue wavelength light which raises a separate
environmental concern at odds with personal
health.
The solution could be as simple as the right
protection against blue light for night owls,
filters that cut blue light in favor of a
reddish tint which you can get for your phone,
or you could just do my favorite thing…
reading a real, paper book before bed.
For more science in your day, be sure to subscribe
to Seeker, and if you’re curious about what
happens when those TV binges go on, Jules
has the details on what sleep deprivation
does in this video.
And in case you were wondering, watching TV
on your laptop in bed is just as bad, not a loop hole.
Thanks again for watching.